oh really yeah she had a guy bite her
lip oh get god when you figure out when
you get to the kiss yeah that really
tells you
it tells you a lot someone just like
this woman like her tongue came straight
out like a like a
like a pen
it was tight it was tight like this
right and it came straight out like a
lizard and she just pushed it against my
lips
why didn't you open your mouth because
it was coming at me this like hard
tongue don't you think you should open
your mouth like if you feel the tip of
the tongue disgusting i mean it's okay
but so she just licked the outside of
your lips she was pushing she poked it
she poked my mouth right and then i said
thank you
and then some just like ran their tongue
all around like right away they're just
like there's no lip wait you said let's
stop on that so where were you kissing
her in the car no it was outside a
comedy club and and what leads to a kiss
like like she asked me to kiss if she
could kiss me she was actually my boss
was really inappropriate this is years
ago but you have a boss at a comedy club
this was years this is when i was like
working and doing what was your job i
was like i worked at svenska
hamdersbanken as the receptionist
didn't speak swedish at all but what is
that it's a swedish bank it's corporate
bank what's it called again spencer
hunter's bumping i answered the phone
like that no you didn't i swear they
wanted me to sound swedish and they kind
of hired me because i could sound sweet
if i didn't speak swedish so you would
go i go straight go hop there's bumpkins
and then they go accept it and go i
i don't think swedish and then
it's the hunter's bunker i don't speak
swedish all day just you're from boston
brian's got hunter's pumpkin and you met
her you did that yesterday
please hold
and then and then she what was her job
she was the hr i couldn't even go to hr
[Laughter]
the hr person at least she was
she asked though she did and she goes i
want you to take my my louis ck asked
yeah it's the same thing
same thing the same thing it's the same
same thing
she said um i want you to take my new
virginity she got she became a
born-again virgin because she didn't
have sex that's what she decided
how old was this person 28
and she was re-virginized yeah she's
like i i'm a born-again virgin she was
from that was her sweet yeah no she was
from new york somebody talking like that
worked at transfer she was in hr the
bank was in new york so then she wanted
to come to a comedy show i just started
doing stand-up and then she came there
and um she asked me if if
i could take her
uh born-again virginity i said no thank
you and then outside the club she said
well at least kiss me and i said okay
and then why did you say no thank you
because i was really creeped out by the
whole thing i knew i i wasn't that into
her too for i wasn't into her right i
mean i wasn't really attracted to her
she was my boss the whole thing was um i
was just not happy did that put a uh a
crimp into like the next day when you
show up at work yeah she would also come
by with two hard fingers and just poke
my ribs like just walk by the front desk
and go ha ha ha ha and i go ow
anyway that was her flirting i think so
yeah i think that was her move i thought
you said at the beginning of this that
it was so much easier to start dating
immediately
i didn't remember so
so you said can i if she says can i give
you a kiss and you say okay okay because
i felt bad about the rejection of that
virgin i'm not going to take your
virginity but you can kiss because what
it what an honor to get someone's born
again virginity
right so then the tongue came out right
mushed against my mouth right and then i
said thank you
and then what happens like what is it
tomorrow
oh yeah that was fun how much longer did
you work there
i worked there for two years maybe a
year past that i worked there
but she ever try again
i don't think so one time we were
driving in a car and i was in the car
with her but she was a terrible driver
and i go can you please slow down and
she goes i have angels watching me
and i was like well i don't
in the back seat
wait you're in the back seat she's
driving you around and you're in the
backseat there's nothing in the front it
looks like i just
you're setting up such an image of you
and schwagenbach i know i talk all
backwards but uh
anyway
[Music]